いやー怖いだ俺なんて言うんだぜを取ります
me ん
ん
ni
1花火社長です思
でブドウ痩せたくないか面子痩せるダンスがあるらしいんですよ
2週間これ続けると10キロ痩せるらしいんで2週間もできる元気がないんですけども
とりあえず1週間だけちゃんとやってみようと思います2週間で10強ってことはこれ
しまいあれば5キロ痩せると思うんだよ
[拍手]
[音楽]
pusan hono デー
voodoo
ラクジョブ規模か知っ丁目集逆どんなホッとして春強いを入れ方意味顔
[音楽]
ブーブー言っは
ネス ono rar
[音楽]
ケロロにーあぁぁあ
tome
nara nara
[音楽]
ん
me
[音楽]
re
re ん
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
やばいいいいい
カチでやばいこれを見てもらったらなんであればからとんですけど
運動量はすごい雷にピロピロ
めっさーせんつけててるしもう床があってめっちゃ売れてる状態です
なんか2週間で10キロ伊達じゃないですねちょっと続けることかわかんないすよほっ
がんばってみようと思いますおやすみなさーい
ブーブー s 005 o
んぎゅう同3倍とまぁ金メッキんがぁ
日目が終わりましたーーー空によって誰だよ
anus どっちファーし
ん90 new ペットを開くべきなんだ
ええええええ
nare
千亀その2期勢山10分やるもんなんだねぇ
ただしてもらおう
なりましょう yeah
par rar 002
ame
ウール
who are you do
[拍手]
8日目でございます8でもうなんかにやる前はきついですけど何とかできるじゃなって
きました今日頑張っていきましょう
汚れ終わりましたーーー
やっぱ外であるよねー
室内の方がその時つですねぜひ皆さんエアコンを止めてやってみましょうから熱中症に
は気を付け下さいでお渡した
たいどれ9どうもみなさん教材室内だったので楽勝でさあ私さも頑張りがさ動画です
がんばりまーす寄せ者数
[拍手]
お願い車
やっぱ何日やっても辛いも辛いですね
13州運動に当たると思います尺魂が守りますはいというわけで11日免停でござい
ます
何度もいませんが何度やっても過呼吸みたいになってしまいますが今日も頑張っていき
ましょう
ええええええ
追われました
せっかくここまで来たんです神のですけど
あと外頑張ります私は今日も元気にやっていきましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
too
was
頑張ります
私13日目だと思ったんですけども
矢部内に絶対なんかお腹痛くなるんですよ
共通なんですよね辛さが分かっているので体が旦那
やる前に恐怖を覚えるになりましただ今日も元気にやっていきましょう
[音楽]
ええええええ
スレ ana
体調によって全然づらいです今日はまず
まずでし意識飛びかけましたという明日が最終日だと思いましたよ
何日やってもきついのは変わりませんということは
前につきれることだと思います明日も頑張っていきましょう
はいというわけで中4日ね2週間最終日でございます a
と最終日に来て気づいたんですけどこの実はこの歌寅卯な増大になってましてやる前に
めっちゃくちゃお腹痛くなったり体調悪くなったり気持ち悪くなったりあのフレッチャ
厳しい部活前の状態になってしまいますそれがほんと毎日毎日やっても落ち着くて慣れ
ないし
まずでこの2週間地獄のような日々でしたら
いよいよそれが最期を迎えることになりました
ただしどれくらい痩せてるのでしょうかまずはしっかり踊っていきましょう
ん
ブーブー lano デー
ブーブー sonorous pou dou dou
女ごっつセッションとはいえ沿い根掘り2 o
ぶー場所ヘアー
あああああああっは
ネス右脳の nar
[音楽]
ケロロ兄てきたあああああ
besame
a エロ
dero
[音楽]
ano
ああああああ
rar
バーン
goo 2
[音楽]
シーン
重量
いいいい
7分
me
不真面目ん
ええええええ
あああん
me
ああああああ
うーんはいという逆に自衛官クラップ乱世30分
毎日ありましたーーー可能
やってみてくださいこうやって見て思ったんですけどそーっとも精神力ないと無理です
もう毎日きついして呼吸もできないので辛いのは毎日あるんで結構トラウマになりそう
ながらきつかったんですけども
血管さんって誰かなと思いますいつ見た目的には結果からもうねぇ
やばくないからこれ普通状態に生まれてはないけど明らかに肉金だけなっている感情し
ますオフィスとはめっちゃ細くなった切らせます腕をね振る動きが多いんで二の腕の猫
のたペンと目がもうなくなちゃいました
また足はないのステップが多いからなんか逆に筋肉がついたかなという気がしました
とりあえず最後に
体重を張ってみましょう2週間に10飛び出す男性って聞いて何でも男性が家でも普通
にしてたんですよご飯も普通に食べたお菓子も食べたし食生活あんまり買えなかったん
ですけど30分やりましたから毎日
果たしてどれくらい買っているのでしょうかいきます
えっやめろああああ
6今まで2週間を取っているだけで合計でやってました
ヤッター
10キロじゃねえじゃ
[音楽]
me
me あった